with a big
chair
[Music]
okay I'm gonna just show you something
and then um you tell me what you think
caused this person to do this
I've seen this video
leaving her unconscious after don't read
it just look at the thing oh no no no no
no no oh my God what would drive a man
so far
dapple throw a shopping
cart at her face dude
and he walked over kind of slow too he
was like that fool went Bow Wow that
guy's pretty strong huh
who thinks of throwing a shopping cart
at someone that's [__] hey did you
lose this guy he's like I don't think I
can pick up a shopping cart
yeah but come on look at you dude you
should you should try but a Costco one
because they're a little heavy oh yeah
they're so big that you could put two
babies in the front oh yeah yeah okay so
your question is what would compel a man
to throw a shopping cart in this
situation what do you think she was
doing to make him that so you are asking
like what did she do
so they were in line at the store he's
in front of her she's behind him oh and
he gets fed up and decides to he just
goes over grab them she was on the phone
wasn't she and just slams her she's
waiting she cut she's behind him
back cuts no coconuts what was the thing
no butts no no butts no coconuts no cuts
no butts no coconuts yeah yeah yeah yeah
she was on the phone did you say that
yeah she was talking on the phone I
can't tell what she's doing she's on the
phone she's too loud I bet she's talking
some [__] whatever she was doing she
couldn't she didn't notice him she
didn't even see it bro her peripherals
but it's a compelling human being to
like pick up a giant shopping cart and
Chuck it at something like that's she
was behind him right yeah that [__] hit
his [__] ankle with a shopping cart
and he was like flat tires
but she had to probably do it at least
like like five times before you know you
would be like I'm [__] over this let
me Chuck a shopping cart at your face
you know situational awareness is really
important in those situations right like
you don't see a guy lift up a [__]
rattling metal shopping cart you gotta
[__] look over your shoulder right
especially in a car it's like a Costco
type of store it looks like it it's in
Brazil so yeah it's like you you got to
keep your head on a swivel in those
grocery markets dude and honestly I
don't want to sympathize with this guy
but sometimes when you're at the
supermarket some people get in the way
so hard that you want to throw a
shopping cart at them but you don't do
it you don't do it obviously what he did
was wrong but like in your head you're
like oh I want to [__] you oh it was
wrong yeah I think it was wrong I think
when you find out why you did it you
you'll sympathize with him fully okay
cool
you set me up besides them right now
okay good so I I think his wife probably
sent him to the supermarket guess some
[__] that she's been nagging about the
whole [__] week yeah and then he go
he goes there all right I'll get you
your [__] hazelnut Creamery just be
quiet
and then he gets there and she grabbed
the last one oh he had to [__] her up
yeah she's like God damn I'm gonna go
home back to my magic wife oh man just
oh did Mark just nailed this so are you
saying that there's two women involved
that it's their fault yeah there's two
women going to jail women can it's oh
they're so crazy
shut up dude
all right what's the reveal Ryan in the
video in the full video they are clearly
arguing about something whether it's
that she's bumping them we don't fully
know according to him he did it because
she was calling him gay
[Music]
you wouldn't believe what she called me
what what gay and then they're like oh
lock her up they put her cups
second shopping cart while she's on the
ground yeah oh my God this is Brazil
crazy this [__] Brazil you don't call
people gay in Brazil yeah dude it really
does say the attacker claimed the woman
said he was gay and bullied him oh
that's [__] up the bullying is [__]
up so you're right you said I would
sympathize with him I fully sympathize
I'm on his team not man the only way
this is Justified is if he actually was
gay because then he's fighting against a
hate crime
but then you know what I didn't dude I
didn't see him growl and then
[Laughter]
but then if he's really gay is it a hate
crime to just call him gay
oh [__] if it was derogatory being gay
she did it with tone and attitude oh
okay okay yeah it depends on how she
bullied him too yeah yeah so are we on
the side of the bully or the
well we don't even know if he's telling
the truth what if he like is just I mean
as a guy we all can identify with what
he was going through a little bit dude I
fought somebody because they called me
gay for real
I'm trying to be cool man like I was
trying to sell it
I didn't believe you one bit who has
called you gay more like jokes
dude you call me gay three times why I
don't call you gay you call you gay
there's nothing wrong with it
cool
cause you gay more girls or guys
throughout life girls
it's more yeah really
really I've only been called Gay by guys
but like jokingly because 100 that's the
hard lines are crazy yeah especially
like if like oh like you want to go to
the movies like I don't got time oh I'd
be so gay dude yeah yeah yeah I would
say all the way up until 2000
14 when it was about when it started to
become taboo uh-huh well wait 2014 is
when gay jokes were really at its
highest yeah I think 2000 no I think
earlier 2017 2008. check my coinbase I
don't know no it started to go down do
you remember though it was like all
right around 2009 to 2013 right I would
say like
like gay jokes to the point where it's
not laughing at being gay but like just
gay like like Anthony and [__]
um what's his name um Lauren Lauren's
doing like like bits yeah like gay [__]
right like gay humor like straight guys
yeah and then dudes would just hold each
other and then like and then people are
getting more comfortable with like all
that stuff right yeah Bromance Bromance
[__] okay right okay and then and then
like there were more jokes about it but
it was like not like homophobic it was
more like right it was just like it's
funny to be homo it's funny to laugh at
people you know what happened before
that too was like metrosexual like that
was a term right that was being thrown
around yeah like oh you're Metro or
something and that was like a
distinguishing it was like later 2000.
thanks Ryan early 2000s people would use
the verbiage and the terminology of
being like Oh you're gay but it would be
more on the homophobic tip and like the
joking it's like a satirical game I said
you know like I'm at home we didn't want
to go out somewhere I was like dude stop
being gay dude 2018 to like 2022 that
[__] was like bro you can't say that
can't say it dude it's making a comeback
in 2023. you think it's coming back I
think I hear a lot more people saying it
casually do you think there's no clearer
dividing line between what people mean
when they are saying it now I don't know
what that means bro
I don't know what you mean like where
where it's coming back because it's more
easily understood that it's not
derogative I think people are being more
intelligent now they're like oh I can
through the tone I understand how he's
using the words yeah yeah but do you say
it around a gay person yeah I get called
Gay by gay people yeah they're being gay
homie I'm like yo you want you want to
go watch a movie and he goes no stop
being gay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah I think some some dudes are so
manly and straight that they will be
dripping like they don't mess around
like Steve Green like Steve yeah Steve
Green would pick up a shopping cart
yeah he has to defend them green is
pretty sis she's fine he's a CIS white
male she's okay she got taken out that
was [__] up did she tell her side of
the story at all no they didn't so this
game that guy was behind
what do you think is worse a shopping
cart or like laying her out a shot be
going to take the report
I think later elsewhere is because it's
a shopping cart at least it's like I
never put hands on her that's crazy
it's metal I'd rather get sucked by a
gay guy
I mean they're buff they are buff a lot
of them are all of them yeah man why you
gotta remind me that they're in a
fitness yeah yeah dude gay dudes are the
most jacked and they got the hips too so
they probably hit hard too yeah because
they're putting their hip into it yeah I
wish I had that gay physique man
straight up they are amazing it is a
funny thing though to be like to be
called Gay that's a straight guy there's
no hate crime in that right if you're
straight well because like
but then that's like if I'm a straight
guy if
you really try to make that world right
and if a bunch of gay people start
calling me gay
I feel like I just deserve for my young
years of saying it the wrong way
and then being like okay it's my turn
now ah
true because you know what I'm saying
it's like we were running around like
you're so gay oh but you weren't running
around you're so head around like that
was never an insult so I'm like dude gay
people won't call me gay just the rest
of my life it's fine yeah I think you
calling a guy anything shouldn't be
considered a [__] hate crime anything
anything cool really well except for
certain racial slurs but
[Music]
thank you